[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it explores his relationship with bruce
and you know not just bruce but alfred
and you know you'll see we introduce a
lot of people and it comes down to like
you know it kind of like it takes a
village to raise a child
in this case it you know it does take an
entire league to kind of you know raise
robin and make him who he is and that's
the uh that's what i felt was you know
really charming about this story and uh
you know a lot of it's heartbreaking but
a lot of it is
it makes robin who he is bruce is the
way he is because of people he surrounds
himself uh you know his family or lack
thereof
uh you know his allies his enemies um
his sidekicks you know you see that
about batman and but this story i feel
like um jeff and i we really made it
where
everyone else is the way they are
because of batman and not the other way
around and i think it centers everything
around
uh robin because the book is about robin
and um you know you'll get to see that
[Music]
i would say the biggest difference is
now i'm controlling the art from
beginning to end so i can actually you
know the whole book's painted
uh which is you know i've done it before
in little gotham but this is the first
time that i've done it on a
you know this story is a little more
serious or a lot more serious moodier so
it's not as light-hearted in um you know
the palette stuff it's not as fun funny
you know
so i'm using a different atmosphere
throughout the whole book
that would be the biggest difference um
besides that i mean i'm very comfortable
with the characters that made it easy to
come back
uh it's pretty simple he just writes a
story and i'm like hey this
reads great then i just draw and he's
like hey this looks great
it's about as simple as you can get and
i think that's what i love about it is
because it's what um i always felt you
know creating comics should be before i
broke into comics you know it's like you
read a really cool story and you want to
draw
and then you draw and then you know
people read and they enjoy it we uh we
talk very little about actual work we
usually just you know text each other
call for fun and you know see how we're
doing but um when it comes down to
actual scripts we just say hey what
would be fun
for you know me to draw and for him to
uh write and it comes down to it and we
both you know we i trust him with a
great story and he trusts me with you
know an art in return and that uh that's
the process we have it's pretty simple
it would be killer croc
i
you know i absolutely love drawing
killer croc he's
he's as otherworldly as like um
by gotham standards you know gotham we
don't have too many we have a lot of
monsters but a lot of monsters are just
you know psychopaths and mentally
monsters croc is one of those characters
that
crosses both sides he's visually like
very scary and just as crazy as all the
other gotham villains but you also see
um you know the side of him that makes
him that way
and i'm just excited jerome because um
when you when i drew him before in you
know black and white there's certain
things i wanted to do with them but i
couldn't because i wanted but now that i
can control the art from you know from
pencil to finished art you know there's
a lot of textures to them and
uh layers and just creating the entire
atmosphere of what makes killer
crocodile croc you know that's what
that's what i really i was really
digging into that
[Music]
you